choosing the game of the month is never
an easy process and August proved to be
particularly interesting this is
partially due to the fact that there
were plenty of great games to consider
as your striker gun vaults delivered
fast-paced action and an inventive twist
on the classic run-and-gun model
danganronpa to goodbye despair pleased
us with its crafty investigatory
gameplay and humorous quips we also
loved CounterSpy primarily for its
eye-catching visuals and enjoyable
cover-based shooting mechanics these
games were worthy contenders for our
game of the month award to be sure but
that prize ultimately goes to Kojima
Productions surprising horror game PT
for many of us at games but it was the
best gaming experience of the month it
was also the most unusual during our
deliberations we were on the fence about
pts eligibility for the award the
self-proclaimed teaser is considered by
some to be a demo possibly because it's
relatively brief and doesn't cost any
money however as the adage goes time is
money and we think PT is well worth the
time it takes to resolve its obtuse
puzzles and to make it to the light at
the end of the tunnel word in fact a
demo or a slice of gameplay taken
directly from the other game teased at
the end silent Hills and we'd have to
exclude it from the running but it's
neither of those at the end of PT it's
made perfectly clear this game is a
teaser it has no direct relation to the
main title teaser or not PT has a
distinct beginning middle and end
regardless of what its ties are to
silent Hills
he can't be taken as a single whole a
might skate that fine line between demo
and full product but we believe it's a
prime example of the ever-evolving state
of games and the terms used to define
them is the odd and somewhat convoluted
nature of the game safe from criticism
suddenly not but it's at the heart of
what makes PT so intriguing with nary a
direct prompt or hint insight its
overarching puzzle asks more from us
than most games players have to decipher
unusual clues while repeatedly exploring
a single evolving setting a looping
hallway in a suburban home that becomes
increasingly tainted as the protagonists
madness blossoms PT requires a
heightened level of awareness and
abstract problem solving skills and at
the same time it disturbs your focus
with Horrors such as tormented fetuses
blood engorged refrigerators and
horribly haunting figures one must
overcome their own fears in order to
find a solution which is easier said
than done it's at times unnerving and
confusing but the combination of those
two qualities brought place together
lots of people including our own Mary
Kishen rough handlery spent hours
streaming their progress or lack thereof
hoping to crowdsource solutions while
putting on a brave face in front of pt's
jumpscares and eerie audio clips
comrades both physical and virtual made
the frightening moments easier to face
and the seemingly impossible possible
forget the pt's the work of Hideo Kojima
and Guillermo del Toro it was its
pairing of hardcore puzzle solving and
scare tactics and it's subtle nudge to
play together near and far that made it
our favorite gaming experience during
the month of August
you